foreign
on Tuesday well cameras everywhere
on in they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
YouTube YouTube Blame as it is they'd
[ __ ] ban our asses quick no you
cannot have [ __ ] tooth
we're gonna have to shut this [ __ ] down
well we have a haunting Mondays and then
we'll have [ __ ] Tuesday yeah
I'm just I'm just using I'm not using it
in the literal sense I'm using it in the
kind of like I'm just like I just I
slept really crappily last night so I'm
like really really
I'm really really tired uh but yeah so
finally finally after you guys bugged me
and bugged me I mean one person in
particular I think it was Danny Rowling
like a one person in particular but it
was more than one person that had been
bugging us to United the comet so we
finally [ __ ] did it we finally did it
and I could I'm sorry we didn't do it
before Christmas it's technically it's
kind of considered like a Christmas
movie even though it's not really I mean
it takes place around Christmas time but
it's like die hard yeah it's not like a
huge part of the plot though and to me I
mean I kind of feel like even though
according to the Wikipedia page it says
that it was technically supposed to be
taking place a few days before Christmas
the way that they have like you know the
comet coming and everybody going out to
see it and stuff like that remind me
more of New Year's so I was like well so
it's kind of like a New Year's movie too
so so we're kind of like in the same
ballpark you know what I mean we got
away with it
hey Dave what's up he says hello [ __ ]
Tuesday honestly yeah but yeah I mean
Tuesday is just it's a day without
character it's such a day yeah you know
what I mean yeah Tom Sykes says the
cover says United Living Dead meets
valley girl
um this actually watching this again
made me want to re-watch Valley because
I [ __ ] love valley girl and I don't I
don't think you've ever seen it with
like very very young Nicholas Cage if
y'all haven't seen this it's the same
production company though as valley girl
this is yeah if y'all haven't seen this
I recommend a movie I I saw bits of it
when it came out but I I don't remember
anything else I just remember a few
minutes I I probably did probably
wouldn't have liked it
in the day that it came out I probably I
would never appreciated it the same way
it's a good movie it's um
post-apocalyptic action adventure chick
flick yeah
um kind of reminds me of cherry 2000
and a boy and his dog all right there's
another good movie which is interesting
because we watched it on 2B and the next
movie that came on after it because you
know how they have that it was Cherry
2000 yeah and I was saying this reminds
me of cherry 2000. and all those movies
kind of almost could be kind of like in
the Fallout
The Fallout video game Universe almost
but this would be like right at the end
right at the beginning it's just two
sisters
who are super super 80s
and but they're kind of like
ideal 1980s which I'll get it we get it
in a second and they're [ __ ] in all
these cool 80s environments in a [ __ ]
post-apocalyptic setting and there's
kind of like humans that turn in most
humans just died some of them kind of
turned into into zombies you had a
government agency that kind of survived
it there were the medical dudes that
survived in a in an underground bunker
it wasn't really a bunker it was a
[ __ ] cave they were living in a cave
that had been converted into like a
shelter
it didn't have a roof on it on anything
but it was just I didn't need it was
inside a cave
and uh they were going out trying to
find a cure for this [ __ ] that it
happened it became it had something with
this comment that went by and
disintegrated everybody and poisoned a
bunch of rest of them
so they're fighting kind of like they
fight zombies and have zombies they're
not really zombies they're they're
mutants
kind of like something out of Omega Man
yeah because they still and yeah a lot
of people like even when this came out
back in 1984 like a lot of the um
critics like said yeah it does have kind
of the same Vibe as like Omega Man or
something like that where it's like it's
more comedic right I guess but it has
like a similar kind of like Vibe too
yeah and like um
the girls uh kind of fall in fall in
with this dude who's kind of like the
the leading man kind of hunk you know
he's the dude that played Commander uh
what was his name uh Commander uh
chicote from [ __ ] Star Trek Voyager
which is I like Voyager with Captain
Janeway and [ __ ] that was a good series
and he's in it and he's Young
he was a handsome dude man Robert
Beltran yeah Beltran Beltran I think
he's a truck driver he's kind of like
Hispanic guy who could dress up as a
cowboy and
you know it's just kind of an every man
in a certain way every kind of a working
man type but uh of course he falls in
with some hotties and they fight over
him and
then there's some zombies okay just a
bunch of [ __ ] happens in him it's it's a
good flick
and it's got a great aesthetic
okay
the the the the score and the soundtrack
are 80s as [ __ ] but they're like a good
80s this is one of the 80sest 80s movies
that has ever since I told Jenny I said
I don't think I forgot to what did I say
I forgot that the 80s was this 80s yeah
I forgot that and she she started
laughing oh yeah Hades was this 80s
it um the thing is though is that we
started laughing
this is the way we wished the 80s always
looked because in the actual 80s most of
that [ __ ] your mom bought that [ __ ] and
it was 70s as [ __ ] yeah I was like we
still had like shag carpet yeah there
was a lot of [ __ ] tacky shake that
your grandma had most of the world was
like that fake wood paneling yeah our
house looked more like the house that uh
Winona Ryder's character had in stranger
things you know what I mean it kind of
looked more like that right
that's what our house looked like it
wasn't like cool with like neon and like
Patrick Nagel Prince on the walls and
glass everything and all that they spent
a lot of the movie at the damn radio
station that they they commandeer the
radio station and it's [ __ ] 80s as
[ __ ] it's like I love that [ __ ] yeah
it's black with [ __ ] neon colored
neon accents it's all over and [ __ ]
geometrical [ __ ] furniture and red
accents and it would have some naggle
[ __ ] on the wall and [ __ ] even the
bathroom was amazing yeah yeah like it
has six like it had like a pink or a
purple sink and like the checkerboard
yeah like a black and gray checkerboard
floor and I was like oh my God I want
that bathroom right now
but you have to understand that was
idealized 80s yeah yeah the only dudes
that had a pad like that would be like
[ __ ]
80s yuppies working for some baking firm
and he's like [ __ ] a 30 and his [ __ ]
pad looks like that and it's filled with
[ __ ] Coke [ __ ] in their 20s so that
that was the only a real cool
[ __ ] a rock or like [ __ ]
Rick James would have a [ __ ]
apartment like that that's who would
have an apartment like that you know
hello though I think later on he was
broke dick as [ __ ] but you know when
Rick when Rick James had money that's
the kind of pad he'd try to live in
and um you didn't see that
when you were actually in the 80s you
just saw that [ __ ] on TV
you know but if you're a regular person
you really didn't see that that much
and uh a lot of the places of business
were [ __ ] 10 years out of date when
you went in there so it's just kind of
funny it looks like if you go on a
YouTube channel called new retro wave
every one of their videos looks and
sounds like this movie well this is what
they're trying to do that's what they're
talking about but this is you know this
movie is like the real thing because
this came out in 1984 yeah you know what
I mean so this is what this is the look
and the sound that they're trying to so
it's approximate it's a monument to the
80s [ __ ] Style
the story is good yeah this is actually
one of the better like post-apocalyptic
films for this because it's like a
different I like that there are zombies
in it but it's not like zombie focused
no it's like they're just kind of like
yeah there's a zombie every now and
that's like a threat but most of the
people are dead yeah so they're not
zombies they can talk yeah yeah they're
more like mutants then like you said
like crazy and [ __ ] right and they're
now I think like the one the one zombie
guy at the beginning like didn't he eat
the other guy from the from Larry from
the yeah he ate the motorcycle from the
movie theater yeah so they are like
flesh eating so there's that but yeah
they're not like shambling like walking
dead kind of zombies and stuff like that
but but like I said I like it because
you know there's threats from the
zombies but I kind of feel like I like
that they kind of kept that to a minimum
and like some of the threat ends up
being like the scientists who are trying
to round up the remaining survivors of
which there are not that many apparently
um to kind of like make a serum out of
their blood you know what I mean so it's
almost like that's more the bad guys
than the zombies are the zombies are
just kind of like every now and then you
come across one and like you gotta
[ __ ] kick its ass or whatever the two
main characters are two young sisters
that are supposed to be high school
students
aren't they high school students yeah or
they yeah getting ready to graduate I
think yeah so they're supposed to be
like 17 or 18 17 or 18.
and uh they're just 80s as [ __ ] man
[ __ ] 80s hair 80s [ __ ] school girl
dresses or cheerleader outfits and [ __ ]
it's just with and then their dad with
special forces so they ended up having
mac 10s and they shoot them yeah so they
know how to like shoot guns and like
survive and kick people's butts yeah
stuff like that yeah yeah I mean they're
they're practical like they're
practicing and [ __ ]
and uh [ __ ] you know they complain
that their dad should have got us that
kind of stuff I like how chill they are
about this yeah so the thing about it is
that the guy that wrote and directed
this whose name is Tom Eberhart and I
thought that name sounded familiar the
reason why that name sounds familiar is
because remember that movie that we
reviewed not too long ago that a lot of
people haven't seen called Soul Survivor
about that woman that survived the plane
crash and then all kind of weird [ __ ]
happened he's the same guy that directed
that okay he also directed Captain Ron
with Kurt Russell
um yeah Kurt Russell was in Captain Ron
right yeah yeah
um and Honey I Blew Up the Kid
uh so that's the same guy that did that
and he said like what he wanted with
this particular movie he really really
liked post-apocalyptic stories and he
really really liked the the idea of like
two very very strong like female
characters
um you know being in this
post-apocalyptic situation what's up
Pokey she's like put me down damn it oh
she looked dead she looked and you could
see her little face for a minute
okay she's it what's up little man she's
making a little mad she's like I want to
jump down I want to jump down she's like
get in already yeah she's like yes I
would like jump down please
yeah she heard that she heard that phone
buzzing she's wondering what that was
it's okay
she's like I got [ __ ] to do yeah
um she won't leave she'll just circle
around yeah she was circling around me
like a little shark yeah a little gray
fuzzy shark yeah but um but yeah so he
wanted to do that and he I guess had
been directing like uh you know teenage
like specials about teenagers and stuff
like for PBS and so he decided that he
was gonna ask like all these teenage
girls that he had been like filming for
these for this documentary like what
would you do if you know the world ended
he didn't say he was working on a movie
about it he was just curious to see what
their input was and he said the thing
that inspired him to write this movie
was that most of the girls were like
that would be pretty awesome like um
they they just didn't really see it as a
bad thing they just kind of saw it like
as a big adventure they're like yeah it
kind of suck that there was no boys but
like other than that it would be pretty
rad you could just like run around and
do whatever you wanted and like No And
and see that's kind of what I was
thinking because
in like um an apocalypse like the one
that's posited in this movie
yeah there's zombies every now and then
but most of the people are dead like
because most of the people that went out
to look at the comet got turned into red
dust right
so there's no
um you know provided that you could
defend yourself against like the the
random zombie or whatever who actually
they they say that those that they're
not going to live long right because
they got some kind of disease yeah so
they're eventually gonna die probably it
probably won't take that long so if
you're immune then you got the whole
[ __ ] world to yourself man yeah and
you don't have to like worry about
defending yourself against zombies or so
so it's not like The Walking Dead where
there's just like hordes of flesh-eating
ghouls like trying to come after you
what's unique about the movie is that
it's a post-apocalyptic action movie it
I enjoyed it
um it's very like
guys would really like this movie but
it's a chick flick
yeah it's still chick flick but in a
weird way it's an action adventure chick
flick yeah uh which there are very few
of those
yeah I think that's what makes this
movie so original I think that's why it
became kind of like a cult classic was
because you know there's been lots of
post-apocalyptic movies but it really it
did something a little bit different
with it yeah and you know like the
character of Sam
he was the cheerleader girl uh she was
the direct inspiration for Buffy the
Vampire Slayer yeah and the unless you
were a guy growing up in the 80s Jenny
probably didn't pick up on a lot of the
[ __ ] that they were doing with her and
[ __ ] just her outfits and [ __ ] her
character and her little poses and [ __ ]
she's doing during the certain parts
their homage and 80s porn I mean she's
she's basically [ __ ] Ginger Lind is
what they're talking about same hair
same kind of outfits and [ __ ]
but she's a Ginger Ginger lead knockoff
which I guess there was a lot of girls
like that but yeah there were and that
actress Kelly Kelly Maroney uh moroney
she was actually in a [ __ ] ton of like
classic 80s but she was in Fast Times at
Ridgemont High she was in chopping Mall
yeah which we I don't think we've
reviewed shopping mall halfway so I yeah
I don't think we have and Catherine Mary
Stewart who plays Reggie like the
dark-haired girl
um she was because I recognized her too
she was in The Last Starfighter that's
where I recognized her from she was a
Weekend at Bernie's too which uh which
you know so we already you could see you
could see um
uh Buffy the Vampire Slayer in that
character though just yeah well that's
where Joss Whedon got the idea because
he just liked he likes the idea of like
this kind of very feminine cheerleader
type girl but that was a badass right
you know what I mean well that's kind of
why I get to the Ginger Lynn thing
[ __ ] uh she had she did scenes like
that had that that was she was [ __ ]
big in the 80s so she was like the top
porn star [ __ ]
High School dudes I grew up knew who
that was you know [ __ ] and uh
some of the stuff that they had are
doing on the couch and [ __ ] dancing
around and [ __ ] and like yeah okay their
homage and ginger LED there those
directors know who that was she was the
top [ __ ] porn chick from that era so
they took Ginger Lynn and I think
probably made her and then this and that
and it evolved into [ __ ] buff the
vampires there Ginger Lynn was a badass
I mean she took yeah she was a porn star
you know what's interesting you know
[ __ ] especially in those days you
know what's interesting is that the uh
the role of Sam uh that Kelly Maroney
ended up playing uh that was originally
going to go to Nancy langenkamp who
ended up being in Nightmare on Elm
Street actually the same year I think
she was at I don't know what happened
there but she did audition for that role
and she was kind of like at the top of
the list but then Kelly moroney ended up
getting it instead and so Heather
langenkamp was like I guess this is the
consolation prize oh I guess I'll go be
in Nightmare on Elm Street and now she's
like a massive [ __ ] star because of
that movie
but I don't know it would have been
weird with Heather like I can't imagine
Nightmare on Elm Street like the first
one without
Heather langenkamp in it Heather
langenkamp in it I said Nancy that's her
character's name Tom's asked me if I had
a Mac 10 yeah I had a Mac 10. a real Mac
10. Ingram Mack 10. the only thing that
was weird about it was like one of the
rarer ones from its time it was an
Ingram Mack 10 but it was in nine
millimeter most a lot of the Ingram
versions of the Mac were 45 but it was
it was in it was a nine this one
it was
fun fun [ __ ] fun gun not not really
practical
MP5 [ __ ] beat the snot out of it so
wood and so would a newsie easier to
shoot
I was gonna say too that uh Mary
warrenov is also in this movie and she's
in tons another [ __ ] she's actually
um she started out like collaborating
with Andy Warhol she was in a bunch of
[ __ ] with him because she's a I believe
she's a painter as well uh but she was
in Death Race 2000 she was an eating
Raul which also had Robert Beltran from
this movie in it she was in Terror
Vision she was also in shopping mall she
was in warlock Devil's Rejects uh you
know there's all that kind of stuff
House of the devil I think she was in
and somebody mentioned I think Tom Sykes
mentioned it earlier but Jeffrey Lewis
who has kind of like a smallish role in
this as one of the scientists was the
guy from that turned into the vampire
from Salem's Lot
okay if it jammed like it did this movie
uh yeah there's no Max didn't Jam
if you did get something like a jam
that'd be a magazine problem you know if
you might have bent feed lips or
something and Mac didn't make the those
magazines they were based on other
[ __ ] uh it was based on other weapons
that I think the nine millimeter might
have been based on a [ __ ] I think
that mag might have been based on an Uzi
mag or uh or was it a might have been a
stand gun mag I gotta go back and
[ __ ] look but no they didn't Jam
guys they're still using that there's
upgrade kits for that now you can turn a
Mac 10 into a [ __ ] beast now they're
a lot better than they used to be they
just use the [ __ ] lower receiver it's
got the serial numbers the trigger Parts
they're putting different uppers on them
now
and [ __ ] different bolts to slow down
the firing rate they perfected that over
the time but back in these days it was
just a crude sub American-made small
submachine gun it didn't do well in
service though didn't have a very good
butt stock on it
it was just a wire butt stock and you
wanted something that was more solid
Victor says Whoa 13 o'clock on a Tuesday
we always we always live stream on
Tuesdays yeah almost always like we
always do a movie review on Tuesdays
Richard Brown said his daughter is
Juliette Lewis holy [ __ ] I forgot about
that oh Juliette Lewis man yeah that's
you know the guy that was in Salem's Lot
that was in this that's her dad I didn't
realize that guy okay yeah Jeffrey Lewis
his name is
see I didn't realize that either I don't
think I don't think that I ever realized
that yeah that guy was in a lot of stuff
he was in High Plains Drifter actually
now that I'm thinking about it and he
was also in The Devil's Rejects like
Mary warnoff was right so yeah this is
kind of like a who's who of like 80s
character actors and like people that
were in like other really iconic 80s
movies it's a great 80s movie uh I
didn't it it wasn't great in the time
that it came out it it had kind of stiff
competition and we didn't see it for
what it was we didn't see it for the cut
for the kind of time capsule it was but
it's aged very well
matter of fact it's
the the the Gestalt of this movie has
[ __ ] actually come back around in
style this could [ __ ]
you know gen Z would love this movie
gen Z would love yeah I mean this has a
massive cult following and so well I'm
gonna say that when it came out
um it actually like kicked ass but um
and got like really good reviews and it
made a lot of money and stuff like that
and I think that that's even more
admirable because it came out pretty
much the same time like maybe within a
week as Nightmare on Elm Street okay
which was like a massive like cultural
hit you know what I mean so the fact
that this came out now I will say that
the reason that it made a lot of money
too one of the reasons was that it only
cost seven hundred thousand dollars to
make
I remember it coming out and and I saw
parts of it we thought it was okay I
think I don't I didn't remember the rest
of the movie
um I remember parts of it when we were
watching it last night but but there
most of it I didn't remember
so I don't know if I saw the whole thing
I don't think I would have liked it in
the time that it came out I was young
and post-apocalyptic I would have
probably I would have liked anything Mad
Max a lot better
uh and I was big into the action and the
horror movies so we were probably
already watching reanimator and all that
I would have thought that this was kind
of like we kind of like light
entertainment and that it was [ __ ]
wishy-washy you know like oh that's a
chick movie but when you get older you
know what I mean you start appreciating
things a lot more you know [ __ ]
teenage boys [ __ ] have a very narrow
[ __ ] field of Interest
you know so yeah there's no titties get
the [ __ ] out there was in this movie I
think winner well there wasn't there
wasn't bear titties there was a there
was a bra shot yeah
but I don't think you got to see
anything no we would have liked it
probably yeah for that aspect you know
what I mean uh but well because I said
like the one point where where Kelly
Maroney like goes to the bathroom and
takes her shirt off yeah and like you
just see her bra I don't think you see
her naked boobies I don't remember
seeing any boobies but um yeah when you
see her bra it's just kind of like oh
there you go teenage boys
as a teenage boy I guarantee we liked
those girls I don't remember anything
about it but we would have liked it that
was right up our alley
yeah yeah
and like I said I like the thing that I
like the best about this like just the
characters are just so likable yeah and
I just really like I like how they don't
make a big huge deal like obviously
they're just like oh [ __ ] you know like
everybody's dead but they kind of like I
don't know if I'd say that they are kind
of like optimistic about it but they're
just kind of like oh well [ __ ] happens
you know what I mean and they just kind
of like let's go to the mall and have a
good time and you know they don't seem
overtly upset about it which I thought
was kind of you know no one's freaking
out or I'll tell you one thing that I
liked about it
nowadays if you have a like a chick
flick there are guys in it but most of
the guys are kind of clownish
this one as soon as that [ __ ] truck
driver showed up and he was in the
darkness he yelled out I recognize that
voice immediately I was like man that's
chicote from [ __ ]
and he shows up and he he's a g in it
you know what I mean he's Brave he does
a bunch of [ __ ] he [ __ ] saves uh
saves the girls a couple times [ __ ]
rescues rescues them but he's not a jerk
about it like every everybody's just
kind of on equal footing which I really
really liked yeah but I liked the fact
that they didn't they didn't turn him
into there he wasn't clownish he wasn't
a clown yeah you know what I mean he was
he was a viable hero but so are the
girls yeah that's what I mean everyone's
on equal footing like nobody was like
they had different skill sets right like
the girls weren't necessarily like
damsels in distress or anything like
that like they could take care of
themselves but kinda kinda but yeah it's
just like anything else no no man is an
island in a situation like that exactly
everybody got to stick together right
but yeah and I think that they did a
good job of like putting that across and
he was a very likable character too like
when he showed up you see if they it
would not have made sense
and they would have tried to do this in
a in a movie that they made today
it wouldn't have made sense if dude was
a clown
okay and didn't have any [ __ ]
physical physicality or physical
strength or any skills to back up his
[ __ ]
it wouldn't have made sense that they
were fighting over
you know what I mean because they were
fighting over him because he was a good
dude so that makes a lot more sense you
know like like Jen said
they were all members of a team it's not
like they were not like they were
totally dependent on them but they were
dependent on a group
Synergy to get through all this [ __ ]
and uh he was a good looking guy in the
[ __ ] he was they thought he was the
last man on Earth so they're kind of
fighting over yeah the only other guys
they ran into were like basically rapist
rapist zombies and they're not really
zombies like you know when like they're
[ __ ] nuts like they're in this
there's the one scene where they go to
the shopping mall and they got all this
free [ __ ] and somebody's watching them
on the cameras
and it's a group of like six dudes all
armed and [ __ ] and they're [ __ ]
attacking the girls and [ __ ] you know
shooting at them and I'm going woman
what the [ __ ] are they doing this is the
end of the world they're shooting at the
last of the cute girls
then it turns out well what they're not
normal you know and it made more sense
after that I was like who wrote this
[ __ ]
um
but then the dude took his glasses off
and they weren't human
yeah they they had started to mute yeah
they were mutated because that what
they're I mean the premise of the movie
is that if you weren't killed by if you
weren't like made into dust by the comet
like from the outset which most people
were like if you were for example like
in some place where you only got
partially exposed then you would kind of
like start to zombie out and eventually
you would die like it well it didn't
seem to take that long actually yeah you
see in a pandemic
situation where [ __ ] 90 something
percent of all the damn even it wouldn't
even take that much even if only 60
percent of the people died off
there'd be chaos for a while but there'd
be a plenty of free [ __ ] sitting around
all right the thing is is that there'd
be more [ __ ] than there are people
so the stuff wouldn't be that valuable
yeah that's what we were saying they
wouldn't be fighting over anything what
would be valuable is people of breeding
age
that's
young pretty women that could have
children and Young Vero men would be the
most valuable thing okay because they'd
be the next generation and they'd be
much would it be worth a lot more than
even food
because canned food survives
indefinitely and once the population is
gone there's gonna be a lot of canned
food around yeah there's no need to
fight over it it's just everywhere yeah
and you the survivors would probably be
able to just eat can't live off of
especially if it's 90 mortality there'd
be enough stored food that the survivors
would probably never have to [ __ ]
plant anything in their in their life
they'd be dead by the time they ran out
of dead cans now you'd have to plan for
the future and restart yeah you know
they would they would plant anyway I
mean I probably would anyway just so you
wouldn't have to eat canned food all the
time yeah and you had to pass the
knowledge off to Future Generations
because they won't be able to survive on
canned food it'll it'll run out yeah
generations and you there'll be animal
husbandry you know where they're [ __ ]
raising cattle again and [ __ ] sheep
meat is actually easier than vegetables
because it's not seasonal and it feeds
itself and then you just eat them you
know so you have sheeps and chickens
everywhere you know let them eat
what grows naturally and then you eat
them it's a lot easier lifestyle than
planting but planting can support large
populations but you gotta have a lot of
planning and you better [ __ ] keep an
eye on that damn calendar and you're
going to need fertilizers you know so
but
so that's what I was getting at in a
[ __ ] true apocalypse what would
matter the most is people
because you're going to be bored
you know yeah there's not gonna be any
[ __ ] TV and [ __ ] it's just the [ __ ]
DVD you're gonna have that hey I can
read I'm good with that
[Laughter]
you know what I mean I've got to be more
books than you could read well that's
what I'm saying I'd never really right
aren't I always complaining it's like
[ __ ] I haven't even put up a book review
this week because I haven't even read
the one that I was supposed to read yeah
which I feel bad about like so there's
millions of books I would never get
bored there's like so much we went back
to that though you'd probably have a lot
of stuff that you'd have to be doing
every day they're your daily chores
would be off the [ __ ] charts yeah a
lot of it be collecting eggs [ __ ]
putting animals out just like you seen
me do it when I was [ __ ] running a
farm you got a [ __ ] well yeah it is a
lot of work right and then if you're
[ __ ] growing on top of that then that
there and then there's a bunch of [ __ ]
you got to do
I think for a while I would just chill
and eat canned food yeah
try to hire other people to grow stuff
right and handling animals is far
simpler I'm good at that I don't like
[ __ ] plan I'm we're doing some out
back here it's it's tough it's harder
it is it's like some of the stuff grows
really easy but like some of like like I
said we got eggplants out the ass like
we just can't even eat all the eggplants
I lost a lot of crops on that last on
that freeze a couple of [ __ ] days
back yeah tomorrow it happens in Florida
too it went to tomatoes yeah yeah
well it happened I got I got everything
it takes to it'll bring back anyway it
was at the end of the season we're gonna
reset it you know it'll be out right
it'll be all right when I should have
brought all that [ __ ] in
instead of having fixed stuff it's
better to have everything in bags and
you just bring the bag and then just
bring the bag inside yeah and then there
was enough room in this house I could
have brought the entire little crop in
uh for a couple of days yeah just left
it at Warren just left it down in a warm
and then taking it right back out and it
would have continued
yeah that's the Go I mean normally in
Florida you don't usually have to worry
about it because it usually only freezes
like maybe one or two nights a year yeah
um you know what I mean but we had a bad
one like right around Christmas y'all
are learning to grow use grow bags that
big around a lot cheap just leave them
sitting outside and you know you can
arrange them and make a little pretty
display
you know [ __ ] lay down that black
tarp so grass doesn't grow in between
them all and put bricks around them and
if you have to bring them in you can
bring them in just put I got a little
cart you can put it on I brought some of
them in but I couldn't bring them all in
because I I was when we moved here we
hired somebody to make me a planning
planner that's not the way to go wasted
money on that should have just been for
nothing but bags
bags in a pretty setting yeah the bags
can be moved yeah easier they're more
mobile yeah
yeah Tom Sykes says wouldn't the nuclear
power plants go Haywire without humans
running yeah I said that yeah Victor
said Life After People which is that's a
great show by the way uh shows what
would happen to nuclear plants they
would melt down without human
intervention yeah yeah we were wondering
about because like um on the day after
it happens
when Reggie goes back to the house to
see if Sam is okay
um the power is still on and when
they're at the mall like the power's
still on and stuff and we're wondering
like how long would the power stay like
hypothetically in 1984 how long would
the power stay on without anybody around
to maintain I was thinking that a coal
plant would probably run a couple days
yeah I was thinking that a nuclear plant
because you're gonna have to keep
putting coal in it right so I would
think a coal plant would probably only a
couple days
and I was thinking a nuclear plant a few
weeks before something would have
something would have to change a button
or something would need a human decision
every couple weeks probably and if that
decision isn't made it probably shuts
itself down
a modern plant probably would be some
kind of an emergency default system and
it'd probably [ __ ] damn pull the
control pull the fuel rods out there's
going to be some something in there I
don't think a nuclear power plant could
just run unsupervised for very long
yeah probably not so that's that's kind
of what we were thinking about I'm like
yeah we're probably thinking too much
about this movie but I mean that's why
people like post-apocalyptic movies
because you can kind of like put
yourself in that scenario and say like
what would happen because people are
fascinated by that kind of stuff because
I was like watching that kind of [ __ ]
too and I was just kind of like like you
were saying because there were so few
people left around that you know and
then there was like the odd zombie every
now and then which was you know kind of
a pain but nothing you couldn't deal
with like I said it wasn't like walking
dead where you had [ __ ] hordes of the
[ __ ] that just like overwhelmed you so
it would really be easy to deal with
especially if we're in the middle of a
big city and that was just like you know
canned food everywhere and there was
just [ __ ] everywhere you could just go
and take whatever you wanted in an
apocalyptic situation it might be a good
idea to have a damn Geiger counter and
you'd also want to know your local
infrastructure whether or not your local
power plant is nuclear or coal you want
to know a bunch of stuff is that [ __ ] up
upwind from you or is it downwind from
you that kind of stuff
that way if
a power plant was going bad you'd want a
tiger counter to know whether or not
you're being irradiated
that way if you're [ __ ] if it's
clicking off some RADS that are too high
you might want to move you're going to
want to move yeah you're going to want
to get the [ __ ] out of there
um
although you know there's no telling me
it could be that that [ __ ] might be in
the atmosphere and other ones far away
is hitting you you want to know how much
RADS you can take
over yeah it would probably be good to
invest in that I mean like I said you
could just go steal one from a store No
One's Gonna Stop you
I don't know if stores have Geiger
counters well no I'm just saying you
just like go [ __ ] get it from
something I'm sure I'm sure you can get
one
but um what I was gonna say what was I
gonna say
um oh we were wondering about because I
was like that looks like they really did
shoot it in LA
uh they did they did okay and like I
said it only cost seven hundred thousand
dollars to make I'm assuming that they
shot it like Sunday mornings like early
with nobody because man there is nobody
there's no cars there's no nothing
I think every now and then I didn't
notice this but when I was watching like
some other reviews of it like I think
minty
comedic Arts did one and he kind of like
showed they're like oh in a couple shots
you can see like a random person like
over on the sidewalk or like a window
washer like up on one of the uh one of
the buildings or something like that but
I didn't really notice that while I was
watching it because I'm sitting there
going how the [ __ ] did they do this like
because I'm like I'm sure this was a low
budget movie and I said it looks like LA
but I was like could they really have
shot it in downtown L.A with like nobody
around they did yeah and that's like
[ __ ] crazy to me because it looked
like because you were thinking maybe
they shot in Detroit yeah I thought I
saw the rim center no it was LA because
I looked up on IMDb and they showed like
all the places where they shot it
because I'm assuming if you only have
seven hundred thousand dollars to make a
movie then you're gonna have to just
like film in locations you don't really
have a lot of money to like build your
own sets or locations or nothing like
that all my Hispanic guys are in there
talking about the chicote from [ __ ]
start from Star Trek Voyager he was in
there [ __ ] some guy says I didn't
know he was Chicano yeah yeah chicote
wasn't well you know oh on this on on
Star Trek Voyager he was playing uh
something from the Marquis I think is
what he was and he had his own damn back
background he was kind of like a kind of
like a uh kind of like a Native American
type from another planet there was some
kind of Civil War [ __ ] secret police
that he was in he would be a Native
American if he was from another planet
yeah well
they ended up just kind of having that
kind of style they don't have America on
other planets not well that I know of
it was a civilization you know what
you're talking about you don't know Star
Trek
Kirk goes to another man and knocks up a
Native American Girl remember yeah I
know and they called him what's his name
kurok karaoke Rock yes
turak was From Another Dimension and
he's a Native American that's another
video I don't know what you're talking
about there's Native Americans
they're [ __ ] everywhere man I got
that good style you know
but uh no he's it was Chicano yeah
look at hilarious and in this one he uh
he does a special operation where he
dresses up as a cowboy [ __ ] and play
some like just really tragic horrible
like country music on there yeah and he
goes he goes straight redneck with him
a lot of people don't understand that
[ __ ] Mexicans are rednecks they got
the cowboy boots and the [ __ ] hats
and [ __ ] you know what I mean they got
Cowboy cultures too man Vaqueros
I thought that he did that like to
disarm the the guard because it's like
nobody would be threatened by somebody
like that they would just think that he
was just like some hayseed or whatever
look man here and they didn't explain it
but I thought that's what they were here
in the United States a [ __ ] Cowboy
he's gonna wear them cowboy boots right
and he's the size of his dicks we
measured by how much that [ __ ] belt
hangs down on the side right in Mexico
the size of the size of a Cowboys dick
has to do with how how how long the toes
on his cowboy boots are on they sent me
that from Mexico all right if I can
some of them cowboy boot toes are six
feet long they come out and they're
[ __ ] curl up remember when I showed
you that yeah yeah yeah
it's showing off showing off the size of
his phallus
as his manhood judged by how [ __ ]
long the toes yeah you just have them
coming up at least
and like it comes around like oh like
that yeah like like a Hot Wheels race
track just like all the way around kind
of a salon [ __ ] sent me sent me that
photograph to prove
next is superiority they're [ __ ]
their rednecks feet are rednecks man
[ __ ] bigger [ __ ] bigger I believe
it yeah hell yeah sorry I was laughing
at it because Victor said I knew chicote
was Latino because in one episode of
Voyager he has all his pots and pans in
the oven
I do that too though
you're white as [ __ ] my cast iron stuff
I put in the oven well I mean where else
she gonna put it well you need it fast
that's what I'm saying it's a good place
to put it yeah I mean you got to
remember the shit's in there like if
you're gonna use it right you know what
I mean because I think we've had a
problem where I think we've turned on
the oven like to cook something I
haven't forgot something's in there and
we're like oh [ __ ] I forgot how that was
in there yeah
I don't I don't know I don't know how
Mexicans and Chicanos are with cast iron
but [ __ ] being from Mississippi I'm I
grew up with cast iron culinary culture
if [ __ ] there's cast iron [ __ ] at my
dad's house I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm gonna
inherit that [ __ ] they don't even make
it anymore
yeah that [ __ ] lasts forever if you take
care of it you got a saucepan it's only
four inches in diameter and flat a
little thing like just a little bit made
out of cast iron a challenge you to find
find something like that I think they do
make those little I think they make
those little bitty ones yeah pots with
lids cast iron Lids on them
and that shit's worth a minute nowadays
I don't even think they make much cast
iron like they used to
that I don't [ __ ] copper well I feel
like copper pants a lot of people since
they since a lot of people have gone
into like foodie culture and everything
like that I do think that people are way
more into like cast iron pan I bet you
have cast irons and I bet you cast
iron's like hundreds of dollars just for
a [ __ ] I don't know I a couple years
back I bought you for Christmas or your
birthday or something like that a cast
iron griddle yeah I got it how much was
that and that was fifty dollars that's
it okay I think it was only fifty
dollars it's got a flat side and the
other side is a corrugated side yeah so
you could have [ __ ] sear lines or
just flat like so you can do anything
it's nice it's Lodge I think Lodge is a
good brand they're not horribly
expensive it's about that big and about
that tall you can put it on an electric
stove range top and have and it'll cover
two burners and you can get it hot on
there can get it hot enough to cook on
it it's nice it's real nice and you
gotta cure it you put [ __ ] vegetable
oil on it and bacon and yeah you can
make all kind of [ __ ] on it the original
note non-stick man I haven't had
pancakes in a long time no it's just you
want pancakes now no I'm just saying I
haven't had those in a long time all
right I was I was watching a video a
couple days ago that like somebody was
making some and I was like God damn that
sounds really good
um Tom Sykes said I'm surprised Regina's
character didn't realize that
convertible driver was the DMK gamertag
yeah it's like that I had forgotten
about that little because I've seen this
movie before but it had been like
several years and it's like that made me
laugh out loud like when that guy at the
end like drove away and said DMK all
right Garcia and El padrio and they're
going oh no no we got cast iron in the
oven yeah we're all Mexican together
like I said it seems like the best thing
it's the best place to put it man
because you use it all the time I mean
we use a lot we make pizza in that [ __ ]
yeah sometimes you can make a deep dish
pizza in there you can we made we've
made quiche in there before
yeah yep
yeah we made it yeah now you're now
you're [ __ ] with me because you know
that big cast iron griddle that you gave
me uh-huh
I could put that I could put bread dough
on there and make a big old long like a
flatbread flatbread pizza on that yeah
you could put that in there
you go that'd probably be really good
because I've been doing that in that
little in that little electric oven with
that non-stick although that works good
too that works too but what if I want
something three times that size well
then there you go there it is that's how
you do here it is we're gonna try that
we're gonna try it out yeah try it out
okay we're gonna use that Tom Sykes said
is this film worth owning yes if you if
you like 80s movies and you like
post-apocalyptic move this is one of the
better yeah because because it
definitely has like a good angle to it
and I really really like all the
characters I really just I like that
just the angle that they approached it
from you know what I mean because it's
not like your regular like I said it's
not like a Mad Max like action type of
thing
um you don't usually see a
post-apocalyptic movie with these type
of characters and I think it really
works you know what I mean because they
don't like go overboard with it it's not
like zany or anything like that but it's
just like very matter of fact and I
think and I that's what I really liked
about it actually
was that it was just kind of like
you know they weren't like over-the-top
Valley girls but they were kind of like
that I guess they were kind of poking
fun at at the contemporary culture the
culture yeah but they weren't making the
girls out to be you know clowns you know
per se no yeah I mean they were both
like very intelligent like resourceful
yeah characters trying to survive yeah
and the guy characters were good yeah
that characters were good they were
believable
and in the end you find out who the dude
was who kept beating what's her name on
Tempest
he's a yuppie and he survived too I know
and she's always she goes under the
convertible she's like nice car he's
like I got 23 of them
because like I said nobody's nobody's
using them so might as well then he
drives away and says dfk on that yeah
that was kind of one of the things
because uh Reggie's character uh she was
like a big uh she obsessed with playing
the video game Tempest at the movie
theater where she worked and she had all
the high scores except for that one
person that was like I think if they
were number six or something they were
DMK she's like who the [ __ ] is this it's
like [ __ ] up all my top ten you know
what I mean everybody's talking about
who's got it on Blu-ray yeah
yeah so people so a lot of people own
this film yeah like I said this is a big
um you know it did really well at the
box office like I said it only costs 700
000 to make and it made 14 and a half
million back so it was very good and
actually it did so well that they were
thinking about doing a sequel
pretty much as soon as it came out
they're like they want to do a sequel
you know what I mean but it just never
happened because like the right they you
know the rights of it like changed hands
and they weren't really sure who I think
that somebody like as of 2019 they were
talking about remaking it but I don't
know if that's gonna happen or not I
haven't heard anything about it like
more recently than 2019. okay if you've
seen this movie and you like it there's
two movies that you need to see if you
haven't seen them you want to see Cherry
2000 and you want to see boy and his dog
boy and his dog Stars Don Johnson young
Don Johnson okay uh you can only get
that movie uh bootleg this I've bought I
bought a Blu-ray a fake Blu-ray copy on
um
on
um uh [ __ ] eBay and I have it
it's the best it's pretty good quality
copy uh it's got a label and everything
because uh the movie's out of print and
it's because Don Johnson is in a
post-apocalyptic world he is a serial
rapist all right he rapes girls and
kills them pretty much yeah but he's the
hero all right and he's got a damn dog
controversial yeah he's got a dog he can
talk to
and the dog is like a cybernetic [ __ ]
dog yeah it's a leftover from before the
world got destroyed and the dog helps
him track down girls yeah all right and
um he ends up getting
chosen
to be taking his breeding stock by a
subterranean
culture that's tried to try it's
basically trying to live the 1950s
forever
and it turns out that it's like
something out of Fallout the problem is
is that [ __ ] they're gonna kill him
afterwards he's got to get the [ __ ] out
of there it's it's it's a good [ __ ]
movie all right
would never fly today okay
um
the other one I recommend Cherry 2000
. it's about a dude and a
post-apocalyptic futuristic Society he's
[ __ ] sick of dating he's like mgtow
men going his own ways so he buys a sex
bot because certain parts of the country
still have
technology but they don't make it
anymore
and he's in love with this sex bot and
the sex bot breaks and he has to go get
a replacement part but the replacement
part is ended up in the apocalyptic Zone
and he's got to hire somebody to go down
there and get this part
so he hires Melanie Griffith when she's
young she's [ __ ] hot as [ __ ] in it
and she's this kind of like a
post-apocalyptic kind of furiosa girl
from Mad Max he hires her to go to the
warehouse out in the [ __ ] forbidden
zone and get this damn chip that he
needs to fix his [ __ ] sex bot
and that's where the adventure begins
she's got a [ __ ]
souped up [ __ ] 68 Mustang and
folding stock mini 14 and
red [ __ ] hair and she's kind of like
a wild west character a bunch of weird
they run into all these weird tribal
Cults out in the desert
it's a good flick Cherry 2000. so those
two movies I'd say they're kind of
spiritual equivalents to this movie
I will say I like Cherry 2000 a lot fun
facts my brother used to have a punk
band named Cherry 2000 after that movie
I like night of the Comet better than
Cherry 2000 though I like them both I
like them both but I think if I had to
pick I think I like not in the comet
better uh boy then boy and his dog is
good too but um that yeah that's a
[ __ ] weird one says yeah remember the
movie nightmares oh yeah with the video
game segment with Emilio Estevez yeah
the bishop of battle honestly I've been
wanting to revisit that movie because I
probably haven't seen that since the
late 1980s and it's an anthology but for
whatever reason the bishop of battle
segment is the only one I remember was
it how was it three stories I want to
say it was three stories I don't
remember but that's the only one I
remember I don't remember anything about
the other ones but I'm sure that if I
watched it again I'd be like oh yeah I
remember this blah blah but yeah I kind
of wanted that's another Anthology that
I wanted to do and I feel like not a lot
of people talk about it you know what I
mean Victor says who needs a sex spot
when you got a Pringle can and two
sponges
that's funny
that's late
get the real thing that's pretty get the
real thing you won't regret it
all right we're getting all tea up my
eyes
Hugo said there's a movie I don't I
don't know what he's talking about
though but yeah so this this is if you
if you like anything about 80s movies if
you like anything about post-apocalyptic
movies this is a really good one
actually as of right now
uh it's free to watch on 2B it's weird
because it was on shutter I felt like
shutter added it like before Christmas
like a week or two before Christmas
but then when I went back to look for it
last night it was gone so I guess they
only had the rights of it a little while
but I'm pretty like it's pretty much
free I mean you can buy you can uh watch
it on 2B you can watch it on Roku
Channel I think
um maybe crackle I'm not sure but like
some of the other like free uh streaming
services you can watch it on there
but uh you know they're in there talking
about the moral ambiguity of boy and his
dog and yeah how good uh that was not
everybody liked the boy in a dog yeah we
reviewed that a long time ago
yeah and uh I think we reviewed Cherry
2000 also yeah y'all want to see Cherry
through 2000 if you like this movie that
is also on 2B I like them all and matter
of fact if you watch Night of the Comet
or at least uh when we watched it uh
Cherry 2000 comes up next like
automatically I wouldn't mind seeing
that again I don't own that movie I need
to own that movie but I think the last
time I checked they wanted a lot for it
you know what I mean I'm gonna spend 45
bucks for that well like I said you can
just watch it for free on the thing and
then you can decide if I like having
hard copies though I know you do I mean
I do too but usually it has to be a
movie I'm really really into you know I
mean that I'm gonna watch like over and
over again like I don't I don't have any
you know compunctions at all about
buying
a really really nice version of like The
Shining for example because I never get
tired of watching that [ __ ] movie
Victor says he watched boy the dog
because we reviewed it okay yeah yeah we
reviewed it a while back I remember
that's like a really weird Tom Sykes
says what's January's movie theme winter
style horror films we don't have a theme
really it's just kind of like what I
what I'm doing is I started
um doing polls for what movie you guys
want to watch us cover like on the live
streams like on Sunday and Tuesday and
usually what I'll do
is I'll just go through all of our
streaming services because we have a
bunch we have you know Amazon Prime we
have a shutter we have Hulu
um you know and then there's free ones
like 2B and all that kind of stuff so
I'll just go through there and oh and I
have HBO Max also and so you just go
through there and I just pick five
movies that I think that maybe you guys
would like and that maybe Tom would like
to watch like I'll watch anything I
don't really care but it's like you know
Tom's kind of picky
so we have to like so I have to like
curate
it's like what what is Tom going to
watch without complaining too much you
know
you know what I mean
so so there
uh Victor says take shelters on Hulu
great movie we that was the one with um
Michael Shannon right because we
reviewed that I'm pretty sure yeah that
was yeah we saw that that was a good
movie
Tom Sykes says the boogers and the film
devil times five AKA People toys are
great winter horror films free on
YouTube
um yeah a couple people have asked us
about doing the buggins maybe I should
do that one of these days
didn't they make a sequel to that I kind
of want boogers to Electric boogin Lou I
guess I don't know all right so uh I
guess we've been going almost an hour so
all right we should probably wrap it up
yeah I'm pretty hungry okay all right so
uh tomorrow is Wednesday and that means
it's our big main show and it should be
fun because we're doing I'm calling it
paranormal palooza okay we're talking
about
in the in the poll like everybody voted
for doing the smurl haunting which I
think we kind of talked about a little
bit on one of our shows about the
Warrens because we did a couple shows
about them but I wanted to kind of do
like a revisit on that and I was like
well I don't know if that's long enough
for a whole show so we might also talk
about the San Pedro haunting you know
Jackie Hernandez and also maybe the
South Shields Poltergeist so we'll kind
of get into like some haunting cases so
that should uh so that should be fun I
feel like it won't be as sold as some of
us we're all gonna be a good show yeah
it'll be fun we'll have some drinks and
we'll talk about ghosts and I love
paranormal and UFO shows you guys know
how I get yeah yeah see I'm more into
the True Crime ones even though they're
depressing yeah they're depressing a lot
of people like them but to me they're
like depressed and I'm like oh man you
know what I mean [ __ ] I like more
like Paranormal UFO kind of [ __ ] yeah
they're a little more they're more
upbeat to me a little more mysterious it
is yeah it is like a little bit more fun
I will admit that I mean because the
thing is well today I've been doing
because for my crime immemorial Channel
I'm working on a big like long video
about the highway of Tears cases like
this series which is almost like I'm not
covering all of them but like it's
almost like 80 [ __ ] murders like all
in the same area and um so yeah so I've
been writing about horrible murders all
day long today Garcia says he's off
tomorrow so he's gonna set his alarm
that's right y'all need to be here on
time that's right yeah that's right get
your drinks ready we're gonna entertain
the cocktails prepared we're going to
talk about some [ __ ] ghosts we're
here we're gonna talk about ghosts
tomorrow El padrino says Jenny one last
question which one of your books on True
Crime do you recommend to start with
first
um well faceless villain is a Trilogy
and they're chronological so if you
start with the first one the faceless
villain that covers unsolved murders not
every unsolved murder obviously but like
kind of big ones unsolved murders from
1900 to 1959 and then there's a volume
two that's like 1960 to 1979 and then
there's a volume three which is 1980 to
1999 or 2000 or something so yeah so I
used to have been good so I suggest like
starting with the first one but you know
they're all good yeah they're all good
and you don't necessarily have to read
them in cards it's just that they're in
chronological order like all the murders
are in chronological order I also like
unseen hand yeah if you're into
paranormal stuff unseen hand it's all
about
pair uh Poltergeist cases that she dug
up that go way back all right and um
parapsychologist Steve bear that we've
worked with before says it's he thinks
that's the the most complete collection
of uh Poltergeist cases that he's ever
seen well I mean I tried to yeah it's a
big book to put all of them that I could
find in there that that I mean had
enough details that were worth writing
about you know what I mean yeah because
I didn't want there's just some thing
it's like oh some somebody threw a
teacup it's like an encyclopedia of them
yeah you're like an encyclopedia yeah
Victor says I have unseen hand on
Audible so he has the one that I read
yeah you enjoyed it I hope so I guess
you probably enjoyed it all right all
right so we are going to wrap it up so
hopefully you guys can drop by tomorrow
and see us we're going to talk about
some ghosts Poltergeist shows and stuff
like that so thanks everybody for
dropping by listen to this talk about
night of the Comet and we'll see you
guys again tomorrow bye he said he
enjoyed it yeah awesome
foreign
[Music]